it's known as the beautiful game but
let's face it it's a complicated game
guys soccer as you like to call it is
like life next season I think we have a
real shot
I'm sorry uh Thomas did nobody tell you
you're you're fired
good news is you got two options option
one that's where you're currently at or
American Samoa
series
[Music]
if we haven't scored one goal in the
history of our country trying to have a
soccer team go they scored again
humiliation
like my words things are going to change
I got us a new coach
[Music]
something to drink whiskey beer wine yep
we got all those which one whiskey beer
and wine
it's safe to say you have zero Talent OR
understanding of the game
so they're not right about the sky what
he is white
coach you've got you've got the toughest
job on the island
all he wanted was just one goal one goal
come on guys we've worked too long and
hard for this you've only been here a
few days
I can't work with these guys for them
it's like some sort of game it is a game
Thomas
giant leadership
grass
thank you for sending us Mr rongan we've
become quite attached to him it's like
finding a little lost white kid at the
mall and telling him which way to go
take a chance off of me